dans la mesure où ce soir sauver le
littoral ce cri d'alarmé qui depuis des
années se perd dans l'immensité de la
mer risque enfin peut-être de trouver un
écho avec ses directives annoncée
aujourd'hui par le journal officiel et
qui fixe plusieurs objectifs dont je
retiendrai un plus de béton sur les
plages de sauvegarde des espaces
naturels entre les zones urbanisées
ça veut dire que toutes les
municipalités concernées vont devoir
réadapter ou réviser leurs prévisions
d'urbanisation jean-marc il ose plus
d'un millier de communes littorales sont
concernés par ces mesures
des mesures qui visent à protéger du
béton et de la privatisation 3500 des
5600 km de côtes françaises des côtes
comme celle ci entre marseille et menton
sans port construit en 20 ans un
littoral dévoré par les grands ensembles
dénaturé par les plages artificielles
désormais on ne pourra plus construire
en dur
à moins de 100 mètres du rivage plus
question d'ériger des immeubles
d'habitation en dehors des zones prévues
par le plan d'urbanisme
mais plus question non plus d'y
installer tente ou caravanes en bord de
mer et le tracé de toutes les nouvelles
routes devra être extérieur à une bande
littorale larges d'au moins deux
kilomètres
par ailleurs le nouveau décret rappelle
que toutes les plages et en particulier
les petites plages sont tenus de rester
accessible au public
ainsi toutes les concessions qui prévoit
des clôtures sont déclarées nulles et
non avenues et les concessions
antérieures pourront être révisées les
communes disposeront d'un délai de
quatre ans pour faire appliquer ces
directives
demain dans l'antenne 2010 nous
reviendrons sur l'ensemble de ces
problèmes du littoral nous consacrons
grande partie de cette antenne de midi à
partir de 12h30 justement à ces
décisions qui ont été prises aujourd'hui
et à leurs conséquences
chaque été l'autre grande menace pour le
littoral français ce sont les feux de
forêt ce matin dans les alpes-maritimes
on pensait que les sapeurs pompiers
étaient maîtres de la situation
malheureusement en début d'après-midi le
mistral s'élever à nouveau au montage
elle près de roquebrune par exemple les
flammes se rapproche de l'endroit où est
installé l'émetteur de radio monte carlo
ainsi qu'une station de relais de tdf le
pape jean paul ii en anorak à plus de
3000 mètres d'altitude ce n'est ni une
plaisanterie ni le début d'une histoire
drôle mais c'est en tout cas l'image
d'actualité la plus frappante de ce jour
en effet ce dimanche le souverain
pontife s'est d'abord rendu dans le
village natal de son prédécesseur jean
paul 1er dont c'était l'anniversaire de
l'élection le 26 août dernier
ensuite le pape est donc monté sur l'un
des sommets les plus hauts des dolomites
pourri bénir sous la neige la vierge des
dolomites
une statue de bronze installé au sommet
du pic de la marmolada voici donc jean
paul ii en anorak blanc arrivant au
sommet du glacier de la marmolada dans
la région de venise
c'est en quelque sorte une première
jamais un souverain pontife n'avait
gravi un tel sommet 3264 m en
téléphérique
il est vrai la raison de cette promenade
dans les neiges était purement
religieuse le pape a béni donc une
statue de la vierge installé en haut du
massif des dolomites il y avait une
autre raison
jean paul ii s'est rendu ce dimanche
dans la région du veneto qui était celle
de son prédécesseur albino luciani élu
pape
à la surprise générale on vous l'a dit
il ya tout juste un an à canal et dada
gordo le village natal de jean claude
monet le pape a évoqué ce matin son
prédécesseur dont le pontificat a duré
23 jours le président du conseil italien
monsieur cossiga étaient présents je
suis venu a dit le saint père pour une
rencontre spirituelle avec jean-paul
premiers afin de sentir encore son
influence de sérénité et de paix
intérieure et trop chaud et tous ici
grain effectifs soit activé dès notre
disponibilité à maxéville non l'esprit
du seigneur humilie tu as humilité telle
était la devise du cardinal lucia devenu
pape il l'appliquer immédiatement en
imposant une cérémonie très simple pour
son intronisation brisant avec les
pompes d'antan jean-paul premier est
avant tout un pasteur ils ignorent les
subtilités vaticane sa nouvelle charge
qu'il est frais il a accepté avec sa
simplicité naturelle
lors de l'obédience que durant des
cardinaux c'est un pape souriant aimable
et tous qui s'adresse à chacun d'eux
ici l'hommage peut remarquer alors de
l'archevêque de cracovie
karol wojtyla personne ne pouvait
imaginer à cet instant que jean paul 1er
se trouver en présence de son successeur
qui règnerait moins de cinquante jours
plus tard sous le nom de jean paul ii
les voies du seigneur sont vraiment
impénétrables
ça fait maintenant trois jours
effectivement que la danseuse étoile
soviétique ni havlat sauva et 68 autres
passagers d'un iliouchine de l'aéro
flotte sont bloqués sur l'aéroport
kennedy à new york
rien de nouveau n'est intervenu
aujourd'hui les autorités américaines
affirment toujours que la danseuse ne
repart sans doute pas de son plein gré
vers l'urss alors que son mari le
danseur alexandre godounov a obtenu
l'asile politique aux etats unis
l'attitude des soviétiques est infléchi
de cet avion c'est parti juridiquement
du territoire de l'urss distille et les
américains ne sont que des pirates qui
veulent empêcher par la force
ludmila bla sauva de regagner son pays
cette danseuse étoile qui a déclenché un
grave incident diplomatique la voici
lors de sa dernière apparition avec le
bolchoï
il y a quelques jours à new york ludmila
aurait envoyé un message à sa mère que
les représentants soviétique à kennedy
ont rendu publique et où elle dit je
serai bientôt auprès de toi car notre
grand pays est tout entier derrière moi
par contre aucune mention n'est faite
dans la presse soviétique de la demande
d'asile politique de son mari alexandre
goon le négociateur américain ici reste
sur ses positions l'avion ne décollera
pas de sens que l'eau de millas n'aura
pas pu choisir librement entre l'asile
politique et le retour en union
soviétique
personne ne veut céder le ton monte
entre washington et moscou
les protestations diplomatiques pleuvent
et ludmila vla slovar elle s'apprête a
passé sa troisième nuit à bord de
l'avion
une preuve supplémentaire que le ton
monte entre washington et moscou ce soir
on apprend par la chaîne de radio cbs
que le président carter président des
états unis a pris lui-même cette affaire
en main en iran
l'offensive de l'armée contre les
rebelles du kurdistan continue mais dans
le même temps à téhéran le propriétaire
de l'un des plus grands journaux du pays
proche de l'ayatollah khomeini son fils
ainsi que son garde du corps ont été
abattus par un groupe de terroristes par
ailleurs les kurdes ont fusillé
aujourd'hui six prisonniers iraniens
mettant à exécution leur menace
d'appliquer la loi du talion après les
nombreux massacres de rebelles ou de
responsables politiques du kurdistan
enfin un des plus grands spécialistes de
la chirurgie esthétique anglaise annonce
qu'il a été contacté par des hommes du
shah d'iran pour qu'il modifie certains
traits du visage de l'ex souverain
iranien
visiblement fait tout pour retrouver
l'anonymat et se dépouiller de ses
derniers souvenirs de monarque absolu
ainsi depuis quelques jours à new york
sa voiture blindée est mise en vente une
voiture à faire rêver james bond
lui-même un reportage de notre
correspondant aux états unis jacques
sylla cadillac en acier massif la voici
reine d'un jour de la 3e avenue à new
york
elle vient d'être répudiée par un
spécialiste le shah d'iran
elle était destinée à partager et
protéger la vie de l'empereur à faire
avec été conclus à beyrouth il y à 18
mois mais aujourd'hui le chat ne veut
plus de cet objet trop voyant sans doute
pour les routes difficiles du mexique
son aspect extérieur ne doit la
distinguée en rien de ses concerts son
charme est ailleurs
c'est tout ce qui ne se voit pas ou que
d'elle on ne connaît pas exemple ce
masque anti nuit dirais-je qui permet de
rouler tout faisait un dans l'obscurité
la plus épaisse est là et équipé par une
société new yorkaise qui ne fournit
jamais les noms de ses clients
c'est un européen qui s'intéressent
paraît-il à elle aujourd'hui de lui
je sais simplement qu'il est latin
italiens espagnols français latin et
riche car il lui en coûtera 245 milles
dollars
plus de 100 millions de centimes donc
pour une voiture totalement silencieuse
un peu plus lourde que la cadillac
ordinaire et guère plus voraces en
carburant que la moyenne de ces grandes
dévoreuses c'est pourquoi sans doute les
ménagères de new york était partagé hier
entre l'envi et l'inquiétude
elle acquit on répète chaque jour que la
voiture de demain sera petites et
économes
même si je le pouvais je ne l'achèterai
pas et cette faille pendant que ce jeune
homme affirme qu'il ne peut s'agir que
de la voiture d'un diktat 1er rac je
veux mettre la voiture en route avec
ceux ci un démarreur automatique
les pare chocs sont en acier super as
yeux si bien que si la voiture heurte
une autre voiture
elle l'a fait voler en éclats selon
james bond
je vais entrer dans la voiture j'appuie
sur ce bouton mais d'abord tout s'allume
à l'intérieur et je sais si la voiture
est occupé s'il y a un ennemi en quelque
sorte je suis dans la voiture et aux
menaces
voilà ce que je fais ici il y à un
revolver
je l'appuie sur la portière et je tire
je suis comme vous j'en ai le souffle
coupé
mais moi je m'en fiche j'ai deux
bouteilles à oxygène pour la route
et en ce moment je suis dans le noir
mais je vous vois très bien
malgré tout ce sont des lunettes pour
transpercer la nuit via le téléphone h f
bhf à l'eau par exemple
allô allô monsieur le président
d'antenne 2 cette voiture vont 240 mille
dollars
oui motorisés voile acheter nous
transmettrons la question c'est promis
en bref encore à l'étranger
les nations unies ont obtenu ce matin
cessez le feu au sud liban et que
l'artillerie israélienne bombarde et
depuis une semaine mais dès ce soir
de nouveaux combats ont repris entre
fedayin cette fois-ci et forces
conservatrices deux voitures françaises
ont été incendiés la nuit dernière dans
un parking de saint sébastien cet
attentat qui heureusement n'a fait que
des dégâts matériels
intervient après l'assassinât il ya
quelques semaines d'un touriste français
sur la côte espagnole
ces actes de terrorisme a ajouté à ceux
de l'organisation basque eta au début de
l'été n'ont pas empêché le tourisme
espagnol de bien se porter cet été
toutefois ces attentats et puis aussi
l'inflation n'ont pas été sans
conséquence comme nous le démontre notre
correspondant en espagne brunois lbp il
ya quelque chose de changé sous le
soleil de la costa del sol
et si l'espagne le pays du tourisme
triomphant avait l'an dernier en pleine
euphorie ouvert des casinos est
autorisée la roulette pour que les
touristes laissent un peu plus de
devises
ce n'est en fait que cette année que le
rien ne va plus se fait entendre
ps est plus chère coûte la vie en hausse
1 million d'estivants ont manqué au mois
de juillet et ceux qui sont restés
fidèles au rendez vous d'août ce sont
autant garder du soleil que des coups de
bâton de l'industrie de vacances
ça a doublé par rapport à l'année
dernière des restaurants commence
habituellement c'est la deuxième année
que je viens marbella qui est le saint
tropez espagnol eh ben les prix doublent
les débats sont très chers dans les
night clubs c'est excessivement cher à
l'heure du bilan les mines s'allonge
tout le monde a subi le contrecoup de
cette relative désertion des côtes
espagnoles ce n'est pas le désastre le
record des rentrées de devises sera
d'accus encore cette année mais
l'augmentation ne couvre pas l'inflation
des douze derniers mois
79 marque bien déclin et on cherche des
responsables au début du mois de juillet
avec les problèmes de l'état quand ils
ont fait sauter une banque derrière on a
eu que d'un ralentissement de 20 % de
touristes pour le mois de juillet et
pour le mois d'août ça et ça sérieux
quand on était dans les normes
tout a été très tranquille
normalement c'est la situation politique
est tranquille
ces vacances sont pour tout le monde
sauf les cas des menaces de grandvaux de
grève ça ralentit tout de suite le
terrorisme et les grévistes c'est plutôt
que de tourisme populaire ne s'accommode
pas des prix de l'espagne démocratique
l'avenir et probablement à une clientèle
qui ne regardent pas à la dépense
il est pressenti augmenté dans les 40 %
certainement secrets ont vite et les
gens il faut s'est habitué pour ses
chances la salle du mans il ya une
clientèle qui sont pas venez en cause de
sa non je sais pas après toutes les
lignes intérieures et le tourisme de la
costa del sol
est ce que c'est un endroit avec une
crime un très bon et tout ça même s'il
ya quelquefois des problèmes que partout
les gens viendra comme elle
parce que c'est l'endroit est unique
comme on les comprend
on a lancé plusieurs dizaines de fusée
ce week-end en france je m'explique cela
se passait au camp militaire de la
courtine ou sous le contrôle du centre
national d'études spatiales cnes
une soixantaine de clubs réunissant des
fanas de l'astronautique ont procédé à
leur campagne de lancement annuel parmi
ses astronautes en herbe une terrienne
monique atlan rh - 2 les sept membres du
great club aérospatiale de strasbourg
font les derniers essais avant le
lancement de leur fusée pléonasme 2,2 m
2 au 8 kilos et demi qui s'envoleront
tout à l'heure à 1800 mètres d'altitude
ici on ne parle pas de minutes fusée ça
vexe heureux rien à voir non plus avec
goldorak ou une quelconque science
fiction chacun à son poste responsable
organisés l'inquiétude en fouilles
derrière une grande activité résultat
d'un an de travail exactement de miller
un travail surveiller comme les autres
projets par le cnes qui se charge de
fournir le propulseur nécessaires au
lancement
d'abord pour éviter les accidents et
respecter l'interdiction de manipuler
poudres et explosifs à titre privé mais
aussi et surtout parce qu un propulseur
ça coûte cher entre 5000 et 15 mille
francs pour le reste les jeunes gardent
une entière liberté etienne raconte ici
le début de son expérience
disons que c'était un coup de chance
comme ça c'était en visite en faisant
une porte ouverte d'une maison de jeunes
de notre quartier et il y avait un club
et puis bon je me suis dit ça peut être
intéressant puis j'ai accroché
ça demande une certaine formation n'ont
non seulement pas on était parmi nous il
y en a qui viennent de qui son g1 qui
est comptabilité et en a qui sont bons
on sait il y en a pas mal quand même
bon bah de ses maîtres sur nous-mêmes
maths spé
et toi tu tiens quelqu'un un champ
secondes ça coûte combien pour s'accuser
c'est une question à double tranchant
parce que on ne paye pas toujours parce
que le but des clubs du club essaye de
ceux de s'arranger pour ne pas tout
payer
bon il ya déjà le propulseur qui paient
par le cnes mais en plus on peut se
faire tourner des pièces par soit les
lycées techniques
ce rapport une boîte industriels n'en
portent une personne qui a un tour chez
lui ça arrive aussi et vous mettez de
l'argent vous même dans cette fusée a
oui ou non il ya une cotisation qui est
qui n'a pas augmenté depuis le début du
club qui est dit francs par mois ce qui
me semble pas trop trop demander et pour
toi à construire une fusée c'est un jeu
où quelque chose tu es stressé a mis le
nom c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
tandis que nonce chose qui peut sérieuse
parce que c'est la mécanique de
précision électronique et ça ça devient
de plus en plus utile ça permet de
bondues ti lisez c212 de faire quelque
chose de constructif
alors est sèche qu'est ce que tu ressens
maintenant ben j'espère que ça va
marcher mon nom c'est la phase la plus
délicate c'est parachute et tant qu'il
n'ya pas le parachute de visible c'est
pas encore gagné
dix minutes après le parachute a été
retrouvé tout va bien
des nouvelles d'une autre fusée
américaine celle là pionniers ont une
sonde spatiale lancé en avril 1973 et
qui le 1er septembre doit arriver en vue
de la plus belle planète du système
solaire
saturn après un voyage de 3 milliards de
kilomètres philippe dumaine en décembre
74 la sonde américaine passait non loin
de la planète jupiter sa vitesse était
alors de près de 180 mille kilomètres à
l'heure elle est maintenant à proximité
de saturne et c'est la première fois
qu'un objet t rès va aussi loin dans
notre système solaire
saturne est mal connu mais on suppose
qu'elle est composée à 60 3% d'hydrogène
et d'hélium
on sait aussi qu'elle aimait plus
d'énergie qu'elle n'en reçoit du soleil
les anneaux de saturne composé
probablement de morceaux de glace de
roche intrigue beaucoup les astronomes
on sait seulement qu'il y en a quatre et
qu'ils ont une épaisseur moyenne de 5 km
saturne possède 11 satellites confirmés
dont le plus gros titans et de la taille
de mars un peu moins que la terre donc
ce satellite est entouré d'une
atmosphère et là aussi on voudrait bien
en savoir un peu plus la sonde
américaine a bien fonctionné jusqu'à
maintenant mais les spécialistes de la
nasa craignent que celle ci ne soit
endommagée en passant le long des
anneaux de saturne même si elle en reste
à 2000 km de distance les américains ont
prévu de faire des observations pendant
13 jours et espère faire au moins 150
photographies
celle-ci ne mettront que 86 minutes pour
revenir sur terre et elles seront bien
utiles pioneer servira aussi
d'indicateurs aux seuls voyageurs 1 et 2
qui ont déjà dépassé jupiter
ce que nous sommes dans l'espace restant
ici pour annoncer l'émission questions
tant de demain soir sur antenne 2 qui
aura pour titre le fil d'ariane quelques
semaines avant le lancement de la fusée
européenne ariane en guyane laurent
broomhead philippe dumez et georges
leclercq honte enquêter sur la véritable
bataille spatiale que livre l'europe à
l'urss et aux états unis pour la
conquête industriel et commercial de
l'espace terrestre l'émission vous sera
présentée par louis blériot avec la
participation de monsieur hubert thurien
qui président du cnes monsieur ron
johnson directeur général de l agence
spatiale européenne demain soir
question de temps sur antenne 2 tirs
c'est aujourd'hui à deauville ou pour
gagner il fallait jouer de 7,5 et de 3
dans l'ordre les rapports 4050 de francs
pour 5 francs et dans un ordre différent
475 14 3 464 en voilà je suis quand même
arrivé toujours pour 5 francs voilà les
rapports s'inscrivent sur votre écran un
rappel en sport vous l'avez sans doute
vu dans stade 2 c'est le hollandais jan
raas qui a remporté le championnat du
monde des cyclistes professionnels
succédant à son compatriote snowman
vainqueur l'an dernier
un regret pour les français et non pas
pour bernard hinault battu à la
régulière mais pour henri chalmel son
équipier qui s'était échappé à deux
kilomètres de l'arrivée qui fut rejoint
qu'à 50 mètres du but dans le sprint
final l'italien battaglin vous allez le
voir est tombé race va prendre la
première place devant l'allemand tueur
au troisième le français bernaudeau et
4e notre malheureux andré chalmin on
revoit au ralenti ce sprint
voilà jan raas turow et bernaudeau
pas de chance non plus pour les français
pour le français a renoué sa renault qui
s'est accroché et dès le premier tour
avec la williams du suisse regazzoni
dans le grand prix de hollande
finalement c'est l'australien alun jones
alan john sur une autre williams qui l'a
emporté devant le sud-africain jody
scheckter un abandon celui aussi de
villeneuve le canadien qui a lui
carrément perdre une roue il part donc
de jones devant scheckter et le français
jean claude lafitte sur ligier jean
pierre jabouille sur renault a également
abandonné il ya quelques années de cela
le château de vascoeuil en normandie
près de rouen fut lauréat du concours
d'antenne 2 chef-d'oeuvre en péril la
réfection de ce site magnifique a permis
de faire du château de vascoeuil un
centre culturel qui fête aujourd'hui son
10e anniversaire en présentant
l'exposition d'un peintre normand lui
aussi fernand léger
c'est le château michelez écrivit son
histoire de france la roue dans cette
espèce de pigeonniers on y expose
aujourd'hui fernand léger un homme qui
par son choix à ceux manière écrit lui
aussi l'histoire de france 2 lui céline
qui colle si bien à sa peinture
regardez les pourrait-on dire où vivent
une époque dangereuse est magnifique
dans laquelle s'en lasse désespérément
la fin d'un monde et la naissance d'un
homme
derrière cette figure anxieuse et
tourmenté quelques fleurs timidement
sorte de 7 à barr complexe d'éléments
décadent et le primitive réalisation un
nouvel espace semble apparaître dans
lequel une jeunesse de 20 ans évolue en
cherchant de nouveaux points d'appui en
reste-t-il l'esprit critique et la
poussée créatrice son face à face dans
la bataille redoutable c'est donc
fernand léger qui écrivait cela et sur
ces motifs industriel chérain son
pinceau ainsi traduit en pâture un
commentaire s'applique tout
naturellement emprunter lui à jean giono
il n'est pas vrai que nous mais nous
besoin que d'ascq et bien trempé
d'automobiles de tracteurs de confort
scientifiques etc
l'homme a aussi besoin de confort
spirituel la beauté et la charpente de
sonam sans elle demain il se suiciderait
dans les palais de sa vie automatique
fin de citation et plus léger encore à
propos d'une de ses toiles il y avait
près de la route
trois pylônes à haute tension en
construction perché dessus les hommes y
travaillaient
j'ai été frappé par le contraste entre
ces hommes larchitecture métalliques les
nuages le ciel
ces sommes tout petits comme perdu dans
un ensemble rigides eurent hostile
c'est cela que j'ai voulu rendre sans
concession fait évalués à leur valeur
exacte le fait humain le ciel les nuages
le métal est bienvenu si l'économie
pouvait évaluer le fait humain à la
manière de légers ceci c'est une autre
histoire
l'abbaye de la chaise dieu près de
clermont ferrand abrite chaque année un
festival musical où sont essentiellement
jouer des oeuvres françaises
ce festival je pourrais dirait presque
une affaire familiale puisque ce sont
les xix fera père et fils qui l'ont créé
et qui le font vivre
on
chaque été qui passe permet au festival
de la chaise-dieu de tracer un peu plus
son empreinte de festival à double
visage visage de grandeur de majesté
imposée par son cadre mais aussi
d'intimité de simplicité qui attire
depuis 12 ans près de onze mille
personnes venues de toute l'europe
ce festival c'est créer seul sans aucune
aide financière de l'état par la simple
volonté de deux hommes de musiciens
georgette 10 francs et son fils vit fra
junior
mais c'est surtout la qualité des six
ans de la bille offerte à la musique qui
a permis de faire renaître cette
architecture jusqu'à leur but nous avons
été frappés par la grandeur et
l'austérité de ces pierres qui appelait
je peux dire une manifestation de de
notre part et nous sommes musiciens nous
sommes dit que ce serait amusant ce
serait joli de tenter une fois
l'expérience de se réunir entre amis
il viendrait qui pourra étant donné que
c'est quand même pas paris ce n'est pas
new york c'est par tokyo il viendra qui
pourra et ils nous feront la musique
pour notre plaisir dans cette
architecture une beauté exceptionnelle
nous avons essayé et il me pour la
première fois la salle était pleine et
nous allons continuer
e
au programme de ce douzième festival
entre autres rostropovitch et audi
menuhin christian ivaldi aldo ciccolini
henry de larmes à l'orgue et bien sûr
les deux chiffres
non
e
voilà avant la météo je vous rappelle
les numéros du tiercé il fallait jouer
dans l'orne 7 le 5 et le 3 j'avais bien
donné cela on voit mais sur l'écran vous
aviez vu s'inscrire 7,5 de voix là
c'était une erreur sur l'écran et non
dans ma voix j'espère que j'aurai pu
ainsi éviter quelques crises cardiaques
et quelques remords la météo donc pour
terminer le temps sera encore frais pour
la saison les nuages seront plus
nombreux demain avec quelques averses
des côtes de la manche aux ardennes sur
le nord des alpes et des pyrénées en
revanche il y aura de belles éclaircies
près de l'atlantique et de la
méditerranée sur le reste du pays le
ciel sera changeant avec alternance
d'éclaircies et de passages nuageux
les vents de secteur nord seront modérés
voilà ce journal est terminé dernier
rendez vous avec l'information en fin de
programme et avec bernard pradines au
bon soir excellent de soirée sur antenne